let's get more now on the latest
proposed round of rail strikes set to
hit the network over the Christmas
period the General Secretary of the rmt
Union Mick Lynch who earlier met with
the transport secretary joins me in the
studio live tonight
um thanks very much indeed for coming in
you've you've had that meeting today
with the transport secretary he says
that he's hoping you would call off the
strikes he's told Sky News this last
night get back around the table with
employers hammer out reforms and that is
the way that the government can deliver
the pay Rises that you're asking for
what was discussed today have you met
with an agreement yet well with no
agreement and the Secretary of State
won't negotiate directly with me he's
made statements which we welcome that it
will be a facilitator so we had a
meeting about what that what that means
tangibly you know and I've asked him for
a document a letter simply saying this
is what my role is and he's going to
clear up some of the roles of these
industry players like the rail delivery
group and the train operators and
network rail what their mandate is to
negotiate and what they can do in terms
of industrial relations so because now
there's some doubt about that with
lawyers letters being sent to my union
saying we're not in a position to
negotiate we haven't got a mandate and
we we can't make you an offer that's
ridiculous I think everyone would agree
it's six months into this they're not
able to produce a document so it's not
just about money there are some very
heavy agendas that they want to put on
our people they want to cut maybe five
or six thousand jobs out the railway
which is serious so we want an
undertaking on job security they want to
change our working conditions very
fundamentally in all sorts of detailed
and important ways such as shutting all
the ticket offices in Britain cutting
all of the maintenance by 50 which is a
serious safety issue and other matters
that affect our term limitations these
are what happens as uh Services improve
the age of digitization is coming or you
don't digitize uh
machines now you don't digitize track
inspections and Bridge inspections and
cutting inspections we had an accident
in Scotland last year where three people
were killed and a train was derailed in
a very serious way and there are serious
questions about the maintenance that
Network rail does they want to cut that
by 50 in order to make the redundancies
so we'll work that through with them
there are new technologies we accept
that and we deal with new technology all
of the time my members operate that new
technology on the passenger side and on
the infrastructure side so we'll talk
about that but we've got to have an
agreement on it not in position and then
when we sorted those issues
you say we are being reasonable but it's
impossible to find a negotiated
sentiment the settlement that's kind of
an oxymoron isn't it why not because I
go into these meetings and I sit this
close to people who are very senior
people in the rail industry I spend
hours and hours possibly hundreds of
hours speaking to them we get to the end
of the process and they say we're going
to make you an offer and then they go
out and make a phone call and they go
come back in and say I'm not allowed to
make you an offer and that cannot go on
they cannot even give me the document
that they're discussing we have no
document to put to our people to
consider as a settlement or even a
potential settlement right after six
months you feel like they're playing
games I mean let's get to the
nitty-gritty of this what are you asking
for and what are they not not coming
back with and also the way you're
observe anything right because they're
not willing to they're saying they
haven't got a mandate from the secretary
of state who's responsible for that
mandate which is why I went to see him
today to clear that up he's now going to
write me a letter saying this is the way
this is going to work we're going to
have a process I'm asking for
ministerial involvement and monitoring
of that he's not going to negotiate with
me that's not his job I understand that
but he's got to put some momentum into
this process so that we can get a
settlement and hopefully call off these
strikes but we won't call them off until
we've got tangible progress and a
document we can put to our members in a
referendum yeah I mean obviously as you
say you're not you're not directly
negotiating with the transport secretary
it's it's with the network Rail and the
train companies do you feel like there's
a a strategy of delaying tactics and it
might not well be their priority
absolutely we the last time we had a
strike was eight weeks ago and they we
postponed a set of strike two weeks ago
or two and a half weeks ago in order to
have intensive negotiations we got in to
the end of that two-week process and
they produce nothing Network rail didn't
give us a new position and the train
operating companies gave us nothing at
all I haven't even got a document to
give to my members and say what do you
think of this so that's unacceptable so
he needs to step in now and clarify what
the roles of his agents are that's the
train operators and network Rail and
allow them to make serious offers in
order to get progress in this dispute
let's talk about the people most
affected by this and that's ordinary
people trying to get to work are you
holding the general public to Ransom now
no that's just a cliche that people pick
up you know this is worthy of the Daily
Mail which isn't very worthy at all so
people throw those cliches at us we live
in these communities we live amongst the
people that are affected we don't want
to affect them my members lose their
wages when they go on strike the public
is inconvenienced the businesses that
we're hearing about in hospitality and
so on are losing money
with Christmas coming you know who
doesn't lose money the train operators
they are indemnified every time we go on
strike for 30 million pounds the
Department of Transport points in
Striking if it's not available
50 million pounds on subsidizing this
strike it would have been far cheaper to
settle that strike on our complete terms
at the beginning it's a ridiculous
situation which shows you that we've had
an incompetent government three
different transport secretaries a dozen
transport under secretaries and God
knows what's going on in the background
over there while they're fighting it out
what they can't do is step up to their
responsibilities to the public and to
the industry which they're meant to
control briefly because we're running
out of time and I've got two more
questions I want to ask you before my
producer tells me to move on first we're
in a cost of living crisis people are
really struggling everyone I I know and
grown up with are struggling right now
what do you say to the person who's
who's a daily wager and if they don't
get to work on time and they can't
afford a taxi to get there and you're
striking what do you say to them well
the buses aren't working the the
underground is working at the moment we
don't want this inconvenience what I
would say to those people who are in
precarious employment created by this
government and the laws the poor
employment laws is that they need a
strong union and we need a better deal
at the workplace what they want to do to
our members is put us into those
precarious situations through
subcontracting and Outsourcing we're
sorry for that but the British worker
needs a better deal they need a better
deal on employment right and let's talk
about that
very briefly
um you've started a bit of a tsunami
haven't you as far as strikes are
concerned well we're glad that people
have picked up on our message that
working-class people deserve respect and
dignity in the workplace we used to have
very firm contracts of employment and
companies that would give undertakings
that they would carry through in terms
of sick pay holidays pensions even
social and Welfare facilities that's all
been Stripped Away and we need to go
back to that so that people feel secure
in their communities and securing their
employment and we can create a better
economy and a better Society on that
basis not everyone needs to be
outsourced subcontracted and vulnerable
but that's what they want to do to
British workers across our society and
across our economy in pursuit of profit
and in an answer are you all
coordinating now all the unions talking
and trying well we talk to each other
yes and it would be very sensible for
unions to coordinate because the themes
are the same the themes are driving up
profits and driving down wages and
conditions so Unions would be dafted if
they didn't talk to each other about
Effectiveness and coordination Nick
Lynch General Secretary of the national
Union of rail Maritime and transport
workers thanks very much indeed for
coming in tonight thank you